because we have this story that uh it
beautifully
jumps us into how critical race theory
is is uh i shouldn't say critical race
theory but critical gender theory
critical race theory and wokism is make
it it's it's manifesting in society so
as we're talking about like cuomo and
women and stuff and these dynamics we
have the story nick cannon calls having
children with one woman a euro-centric
concept the tv presenter has seven
children with four different women
so perhaps he's only saying that because
he's
non-monogamous
what they say
cannon welcomed twins
zion mixolydian and zillionaire with
abby delarosa on june 14th his son zen
whom he shares with model alyssa scott
was born nine days after zillion and
zion additionally canon welcomed
daughter powerful queen back in december
with brittany bell with whom he also
shares four-year-old son golden cannon
is also dead to ten-year-old twins son
moroccan and daughter monroe with
ex-wife mariah carey says people
magazine well i didn't know that about
him holy moly yeah so uh when pressed
about having multiple children with so
many women canon said monogamy was a
eurocentric concept just to classify
property
just like the idea that a man should
have one woman we shouldn't have
anything i have no ownership over this
person if we really talking about how we
coexist and how we populate it's about
what exchange can we create together
those women and all women are the ones
that open themselves up to say i would
like to allow this man in my world and i
will birth this child so it ain't my
decision i'm just following suit this is
amazing the i mean he's basically
absolving himself of some responsibility
when it comes to having these kids
in a way that we're probably not used to
i hear from people all the time the dude
will say something like we're pregnant
like referring to him and his
significant other yeah but you hear that
a lot yeah i know but it's kind of
repulsive like no
we're pregnant [ __ ] you have you been
pregnant you're not pregnant
i guess but the point is like that's the
at least the guy is saying like this is
something weird doing together like i
guess this is him being like hey they
wanted to have kids don't look at me
you know yes yes i see where you're
coming from monroe is a great name for a
girl um that wasn't what you're looking
at for a comment but interesting right
i feel like though to be fair for nick
cannon like he probably he must have had
discussions with these women that was
like this is who i am and i'm this is
how your life is going to be do you want
to do this and they still were like yes
so i don't know do you think or was he
just like by the way you're nine months
pregnant there's two other people who
are also come on like hold on he had a
kid in december
yeah he then now he's have another kid
like
they must know i guess yes right yeah
they must know because they would have
been visibly pregnant unless they must
know unless he hit i don't i don't have
no i i think you know what it may be is
that in the modern world of feminism
these women have the means take care of
themselves yeah so they're less
concerned about whether or not there's
going to be a dad who's going to be
paying for and supporting the family
the cat the catholic church i see where
they're saying about the eurocentric
thing is because like the catholic
church is big on monogamy and i don't
know if they were doing it for control
or if they wanted the the man to stay
with the woman to raise the family um
but like when you look at the muslim
faith they would have a guy would have
like seven wives
yeah but in the muslim world the man is
still a part of the family like you have
more than one wife but it becomes you
take care of it right a big family and
you're there and taking care of them and
all the kids right am i crazy well
theoretically that's what we're told i
just want to point out people in asia
get married
it's this is the problem with this
critical race theory stuff it's just a
lie an excuse to to for whatever
behavior they're engaging in that they
want an excuse to engage in so sure if
it is like monogamy is the the
traditional or social norm and now
you're trying to not do that so you just
blame eurocentric you know yeah
eurocentrism or whatever it's like
asians got married and they're very
family oriented you know the kids how
long how long have they been getting
married for in asia yeah i don't know
the history but i do know that you know
um you just think about the concept of
arranged marriages for instance that go
back thousands of years
i think they would have concubines in
asia so they would they would have one
wife and then like seven concubines it
would be women that they just had sex
with and had kids with no i think i
think certainly people do that that was
an asian cultural thing and like the
mongols would have concubines they would
have lots of
they weren't why that's the thing is
they would get around it by saying you
know she's just my side right but there
are asian cultures that are very family
oriented they were very like you know
they had these these these ideas of um
you know different clans would come
together different families essentially
what what do you guys think about
monogamy in general like
is it the way of the future
i think uh two parents is scientifically
if you look at most of the data proven
to
help raise kids better i suppose or i
suppose it should be the standard and
kids who don't have two parents in the
house end up doing poorly more likely to
do drugs more like they go to jail so i
think that's important but ultimately
i think there's a lot of people we've
got to make sure we don't fall into the
trap of this is the way it's always been
so this is the way we must keep doing it
we need to make sure that we're
constantly looking at like what actually
helps and benefits society now we know
two parents does so it's a problem then
when you see like black lives matter say
that we want to you know what do they
say disrupt the nuclear family
we don't we don't want kids with single
parents you know that's that the data
shows that's really bad for them
so i don't know if i i would say
monogamy is a path towards that
but
i don't know man we're we're a
perpetually libertarian society in a way
now we've got this weird
authoritarianism which is more
disruptive of tradition as opposed to
being pro-freedom
so i don't i don't know ultimately what
happens but i can say i think the
direction the critical race theorists
critical gender theorists want to go
would be more destructive whether you're
for or against monogamy
they would native americans i think and
they may not be the native americans but
there were tribes i think where they
would raise all the whole tribe would
raise all the kids because the guys
would have sex with all the women none
of the women knew who the father was so
they would like collectively raise all
the children together that's interesting
i never heard that to me that almost
sounds a little bit like a communistic
way to raise children it's like when
hillary clinton was saying it takes a
village to raise a child that's a little
bit strange to me and ian you mentioned
the church and that's interesting to me
as well because the way i was raised we
were taught that um christ is the head
of the church and treated the church as
his wife so it was like a big it's
literally like a big family but it
wasn't like that communistic raising of
the kids it was like a structure for the
way that the family should be mom dad
kids and it was like really simple
really fundamental really basic and we
can see that that's a good way to raise
kids is to have both parents in the home
they need to be together it needs to be
structural i'm hugely in favor of
monogamy if possible yeah but i think
everything's just falling apart well
yeah that's true i think everything's
falling apart i've always wondered so
those studies on monogamy not to be like
the anti-monogamy person because i'm not
but the studies on monogamy showing
two-parent households
lead to like more success for your
children
people who end up splitting up
also aren't as well generally speaking
right so like are all those studies
controlling for like iq and mental
illness and things because you could say
i mean if you're going to have two
people who are not doing well in the
same house but would be doing better
apart
i would argue that it's better to have
both parents happy than have them
arguing in the same house
yeah um but so i just i don't know how
the studies were done and then were
there studies before when monogamy
wasn't the main
thing i think
i would i would assume they account for
something like this but it is a good
point i doubt it all these scientific
studies that i've read like there's such
glaring flaws i wouldn't be surprised if
they didn't account for something well
iq i mean no one accounts for iq anymore
yeah anyway
yeah i mean it's a good point though if
like the mom is on drugs and the dad
isn't yeah then it's like yeah that kid
would do a lot better yeah um
although i guess you run into the risk
then of uh divorce courts favoring women
right there there was an old case that
uh i read about years and years ago
where a man divorced his wife because
she was doing drugs oh no and then when
they went to court the court sided with
the mom and even though he was like you
can't give my kids to this woman she's
doing drugs and then she ended up
killing them somehow geez holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah it was some some negligence or
something she was drugged and you know
the young kids ended up dying somehow i
can't remember the exact story i mean
you could probably google something yeah
well divorce court is a whole nother
thing right yo yeah yeah yeah you get
the uh mgtow got banned on reddit so
you'll get you'll get all those you know
mgtow really yeah yeah they got they got
banned on reddit a few weeks ago so uh
you know when you mention all this stuff
the legitimate problem is i didn't know
they got banned on reddit that's intense
yeah
yeah well the censorship it's uh they're
they're homogenizing their view of what
they want the culture to be so they're
excising portions one at a time you know
yeah the legality of marriage is very
weird because marriage the word means to
mix so like two people spending a lot of
time together mixing their energy are
essentially in a form of marriage
whether the law says it or not doesn't
really matter yeah so that's like a
common law marriage it's something like
seven years ago but same person oh in
canada it's a lot shorter i think i
thought it was like this is gonna be
wrong but it's two or three maybe if
you're living in the same household in
ontario anyway yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty yeah it's pretty fast and i'm
pretty sure if you split up after that
if you've been living together then you
still have court to deal with oh wow
even though you're not yeah what if
you're just roommates
no no no you have to be in a
relationship like you have to do it yeah
but what if they say that you are it's
iffy i would assume that that's still
okay i mean when you're filling out
taxes and things you can put yourself as
common law so if you started filling
that in then maybe that might screw you
out over in the future but it's short it
i think it's three years
dude so so i look at look the the the
monogamy and polyamory thing and and
polygamy thing i guess polygamy is
people talking about marrying multiple
women i don't know about about that but
uh we're seeing a lot of these memes now
where it's like one woman like five guys
like i don't know if you see him on
reddit
when she's on the couch
oh no that's a different one i'm talking
slightly different yeah
different one but uh we know that one
we're all familiar with that one there's
like there's memes of like it'll be like
four dudes on a couch and they all have
their arms around like the one one woman
and uh it's talking about like you know
polyamorous relationships and things
like that attractive people regardless
of whatever
there's there's a few things to say one
not all change is good not all change is
bad but i definitely think
this is just a sign of things falling
apart
like to have kids with a bunch of
different women and be like well you
know they wanted to do it it's like yeah
but
i'm i'm sure he's still going to be
there raising his kids we're seeing a
lot of kids in a lot of different places
and he's not going to be able to provide
the same kind of leadership that
somebody who is you know in a family
with kids will be
and more to the point i'm just saying
it's just another sign of i think we're
facing we're facing for a long time
cultural stagnation movies were reboots
comics everything it was just
regurgitated garbage lowest common
denominator and now it's cultural decay
it's just
the movies are getting worse have you
seen warrior the tv show no is it good
it's so good oh okay what is it it's
about that
sorry to interject it's about uh san
francisco and the triads in the 1800s
it's like a cowboy western right now
asian people it's epic warrior other
than that society's over but yeah yeah
warrior
the uh electric dreams i've been talking
about because i just watched that i
think it's a couple years old i'm not
sure old dreams yeah it's philip k dick
like that's cool i like that they
adapted the book into you know our
stories into these episodes of the show
it's kind of like black mirror it's it's
pretty it's a pretty okay it's an
anthology i'm not saying there's nothing
good happening it's just like just
warrior there was a period where we made
new things you know we wrote christmas
music and then we played them over and
over again then it got to a point where
a few years ago i was like everything's
stagnant we're rebooting movies we're
remaking
comic books spider-man 12 you know just
keep doing it over and over and over
again the same thing instead of making
new things now we're at the point where
they're starting to regurgitate the same
content but in worse worse ways like the
movies you know get won't go broke as
people often bring up when it comes to
video games movies
they'll try to redo ghostbusters
and this is where the regurgitation
becomes from stagnation to decay i see
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time